all right what is your name I think
royalty royalty uh where'd you grow up
what are you from
well I grew up in watts South Central
yes and tell me about your family you
grew up with both your parents um yes my
stepdad and how was your childhood well
in beginning it was okay then um we
ended up in foster care and like we were
separated
who's we you and your me and my siblings
oh it was like six of us
I basically was taking care of my
sisters because my I said dad had a
gambling problem and my mom
she basically dipped like left like four
sometimes week sometimes days and I was
left taking care of my my said man are
you the oldest yeah
what it's when I was just raised taking
care of him at a young age I was like
six years old taking care of my siblings
and then how are your teenage years
actually um I spent 13 years old from
juvenile hall
I went from juvenile hall to the
compound and from the compound not with
the prison
what were you in juvenile hall for in
prison for killing the person that
solemnize me could you kill my husband
it also in the foster home you got he
was molesting you and how did you murder
him um I found again with somebody that
took me in basically he knew what I
wanted to do right then and look which
the place and will come up get my choice
it's all young if you have a choice that
you're either going to do it yourself I
have done plenty or I'm gonna do it
cause either way you have to go because
you you shouldn't have to do that to a
12 year old girl you know right
if
because it really [ __ ] with you know
I'm slowing and to do that to me and
then throw me out with nothing like no
clothes like I was just trash you know
it's devastating
yeah so you ended up in prison for how
long from 39 get on June 25 basically 27
now oh my god you just got out it is I I
had dreams you know like to become a
finger you know write poems and not that
name it's basically like you took that
away from me
yeah you spent half your life in in
prison or jail so do you still stay in
touch with any of your family most of
them I do let me and my twin basically
don't get along you know cuz hey
we always argue she fell because when I
was in newborn I had health issues
I basically won my mom gave birth to me
I basically flatline stop breathing I
turn blue and purple I was but not dead
for three hours and my family basically
was treating me like buoyancy like you
know whenever I needed something that
was there and she hated me because of
that I don't talk to her
my dad my stepdad I took to my real dad
I'm fairly just given up
and were you living now I know I'm late
nothing that's it that's goodra they're
using any drugs that are out here you're
not using maybe a smoke we because I'm
still trying to you know do my music and
everything that is hard when you have
that records on you
absolutely it's hard to get a job it's
gotta follow you everywhere you go
yeah how do you support yourself now oh
now I have two bikes one I sell you know
so my bikes need an sometimes so heavily
or you know friends I think for look out
for me give me money you're not dating
guys like a lot of the girls do you do
that Tim that's a common story done here
yes I used to do it again I thought like
oh it's better degraded and basically he
was giving me flashbacks yeah
[Music]
did you have any friends days he he kind
of had a big chunk of your life taking
away from you so it's hard too hard to
make friends
yeah cuz harder just what kind of
thoughts go through your head I mean
would what do you wish was different
about your your childhood that might
have I mean certainly not having a
stepdad molesting you it would be a big
one
I wish I could start the situation out
instead of not thinking and just doing
it and I could have thought about the
situation better me did you tell was it
your mom that could have done something
my stepmom is your foster mom right yes
foster mom could have done something so
you passed away oh so the step to
address she passed away in my lap she
had a seizure so right after she passed
away that's when I hell broke loose
like and all the thoughts went into my
hair like did he do it because he showed
no emotion like so basically I was just
on my own like foster homes don't care
like the social workers like they say
they didn't know you've never had
anybody that cared for you well you
better take care that show they care was
my son
what you have a son I have for you ready
fight in foster home he's in the
hospital
do you ever get a chance to talk to him
you see him they took him away because
he's artistic autistic and he's saying
with my anger issues and he hasn't let
goes that I'm not able to take
responsibility and take care of my son
Liz I have joint custody we new have
blackouts
what causes blackouts my anger
I guess on when I flatlined
I have the blackout's to where I can't
remember and then I have seizures
because I have brain trauma from your
birth yes
are you a medication for that I was
supposed to take me but I don't
so I mainly smoke we to basically come
in
yes
you have any plans for your future
anything you'd like to see happen
basically follow my career like Jean
like I already started writing poems and
putting them on oh hello poetry and I'm
already doing the music like recording
myself
this is writing music and poetry you
find it helpful therapeutic for what
you're going through
yeah yeah bet it is actually keep me
calm especially music like when I get
nervous or something's in I stay singing
yes yeah you're a beautiful singer I've
heard you sing just now setting up my
royalty well thank you so much for
talking me and sharing your story thank
you and good luck with your life now
that you're finally free yes
you